well brian as those case numbers
continue to go up
go up contact tracers are staying pretty
busy but some
actually are in the process they're
question the process if it really works
in order to stop the spread of covid19
how effective is this contact tracing
well eight news now reporter kristen
drummond joining us now live from the
newsroom with the latest on the efforts
but also the challenges
kristin well denise contact racing
requires
investigating to understand the spread
of covet in the community
it seems to work best when everyone
participates and
is forthcoming with their information
which presents an issue at times
unlv created a contact tracing program
in partnership with the southern nevada
health district this year
roughly 200 students work part-time
making calls to people who tested
positive
and their close contacts the professor
overseeing the effort tells me
it's successful but offers certain
challenges that includes
people not answering their phones or
refusing to share names or phone numbers
now when this happens it can either
delay notifications or some people may
not even know
at all about their exposure we have to
rely on them to provide that information
so that we can protect the people around
them
it's not to get somebody in trouble it's
really to intervene in that disease
transmission process so that they don't
spread it to somebody else
professor labus adds when the virus
spreads quickly like
right now contact tracing is not as
useful stopping the virus transmission
and
that's because it can be difficult to
reach everybody and intervene but
it remains helpful when cases get under
control so
more people get alerted now contact
tracing is responsible for about
25 percent of diagnosing exposure
one way to possibly know your exposure
right away
is by downloading the kovid trace nevada
app on your phone
it exchanges information with other
phones nearby to alert if
you have come in contact with someone
who's tested positive for covid19
roughly 122 000 people have downloaded
it so far
which is about four percent of the
state's population so for it to really
be effective according to the state
division of public and behavioral health
15 percent of the population need to
have it